fait partie de toutes les lois
liberticides et toutes les mesures que
ce gouvernement est en train de prendre
depuis déjà quelques temps
en plus des étagères me dire d'urgence
sécuritaire liés à la pandémie qui sont
d'un bon prétexte pour limiter les
libertés publiques et la 2 surcroît
finiront ils ont rajouté il empile les
feuilles c'est un millefeuille
maintenant elle la police a le droit de
nous ficher la police a le droit de
s'intéresser à nos opinions
anou loisirs anneaux inclination etc
mais jusqu'où va comme ça dans ce pays
c'est pas possible quoi pour arrêter
faut arrêter c'est pas de nous annoncer
une réécriture de l'article 24 qui va
nous satisfait il ya tous les autres
articles qui persistent dans cette loi
donc c'est nous c'est la totalité de la
loi de sécurité globale dont on demande
le retrait
et pas uniquement l'article 24 qui est
va être soi disant a réécrit et à
paraît-il en plus pour nous le mettre
dans la loi dite séparatiste ce soit la
loi sécurité globale que ce soit le
texte il ya eu juste avant sur le
nouveau schéma du maintien de l'ordre
dernièrement les décrets aussi sur le
fichage parce que là en ce moment ce qui
se passe donc c'est une forme en des
outils qui se met en place et des textes
répressifs et qui permettent cette
surveillance généralisée qui sont en
train de se mettre en place et ça on en
demande le retrait